can you tell me
you were really kind enough to give me
uh
one of these shirts with 114. can you
can you tell me the story of 114.
um i wear proudly i served eight years
in that command and i didn't finish my
career there um i i i passed the
lieutenant's test and once you do you
have to leave
the story behind tally ho is um
back in world war ii there was this
gentleman named bad jack carroll and
jack was an airborne ranger and uh my
father-in-law was also on a department
and he knew jack
and jack came home
jack jumped normandy and uh stormed up
through the battle of the bulge in
bostonia and uh
he came back
greatest generation as they all did and
they they got jobs they went right to
work and uh
they were treated better back then vets
right and uh he got on the new york city
fire department and he got assigned a
ladder 114
and they first got um
radios back then
and when jack he would drive the truck
you're up there with the officer either
lieutenant or captain so if the boss is
off the truck you you operate the radio
for them as the driver so when they call
them and they'd say
you know a lot of 114 responding to 52nd
street third avenue structure fire
you're supposed to get back and say 114
114 10-4 but he refused to do that he'd
say ladder 114 tally ho
because that's what they'd yell when
they jump out the plane
so all these years later it stuck and um
it's a little bit of a bragging right
but uh out of 350 engine and truck
companies in the whole new york city
fire department we're pretty much the
only one that's uh called by their
nickname on the radio not their number
so
it tweaks some guys off in other places
you know they may hey f you italia or
you know but it's it's just uh yes it's
a great great
heritage and and we're really proud and
uh you know the shamrock was
you know he was irish and a lot of the
guys back then
were irish immigrants from the area from
the neighborhood and they would actually
take the the fire truck to church on
sunday and park out front and and one
guy would stay in it to hear the radio
in case they got a call so uh yeah
that's
the proud history and you said that if i
wear this around new york am i getting a
little bit you might get a guy from the
bronx go ahead tyler will screw you you
know but i mean it's it's
all that good rivalry you know we like
to you know
we like to kid each other back and forth
you know uh
guys from manhattan we'll say yeah you
guys in brooklyn yeah short buildings
tall stories and like yeah but you guys
in manhattan tall store tall buildings
no stories you know it's just all that
it's all that i love jocular ball break
and it's good stuff you know
you